so I want the next one this question
would be I think CME real do this one it
is pretty straightforward
this is pretty straight for so many
question I have a little bit you know a
to find y intercept so that you always
make that you technical 0 and so in that
question you'll just be after the values
minus a 2 or a negative 2 would then
negative with absolute value still apply
to the negative 2 over it like this
piece of you okay well so you're saying
I want to find a winder sense right so
for y it says by the way I always like
to say like what are you doing right
other than let X equal 0 a lot of people
just say X equal 0 into y and then what
do you do and you get a little like with
your in a minute which ones which is why
okay this is y so I'm going to like set
up a substituted this is 0 1 0 2 this is
the absolute value of negative 2
it's little reason for the absolute
value to not be taking into account
so Y simply equals 2 which is exactly
what you could verify here if you graph
developing we can try this
can we factorize yeah we can but it's
the absolute value all what am I going
to put in my bracket X minus 6 or X goes
to plus qualities perfect right so
therefore I can read up my intercepts
immediately there's our negative 132
right now ordinarily I would say oh this
guy's concave up so it could be this
happy problem but I know that even at
this part and this part are ok this part
down here the absolute value will apply
and it goes whoop and visual to okay let
me find my track description um in the
Internet I'll go the history of sender
one of the reasons why I never assign
all the questions in an exercise number
one is because it's is thank you forever
number two is so that if you like up 3a
is the stuff I had trouble with well you
go back to create there's two more
questions in there you can attempt okay
so here we go bass yeah yeah okay so
what's the actual question that you have
to do with that because I just see I
should include a what I do with it
should we grab it yeah and wrap it in
show I'm pretty sure cracking is the
final one yah to do okay yeah they're
both so what do you think about this
there are every time you see absolute
value there are it's a two things in
disguise right so the question is one of
the two things it works okay so I'm
going to say there's a case here and
case here no matter where a coefficient
in front of the material just now there
will be principle 7 now if you have a
think about this this is always building
the same thing is not changing but this
guy over here is it's this
jekyll-and-hyde right but sometimes X
plus 1 sometimes it might have X minus 1
okay so you tell me what is it switch
over when this is the time to be one or
the other
what's the turning the changing point
now this is Scotty go metal breath
you've got to be able to quickly wrap it
in your head is that that part of their
own see laughs see that is pretty
straightforward
see them red deer legs plus one without
absolute values regular X plus one goes
like this and keeps going down to
negative one so I reckon other way under
excellent this is X plus one okay and
then rebalance all right there you go
that's the absolute value of x plus one
this iron here is negative one although
that's something on the right into
something else okay so I'm going to say
there for the left-hand side and X is
greater than negative one
what is this thing going to be equal to
well it's y equals 2x plus 1 minus what
is the equation of the left air bridge
minus X if minus X my planet is
decreasing once so therefore minus X
minus 1 like so well double negative
happening here so this is just a plus X
just want your air
so that is three outside impossible
shapes of three so I'll keep that in my
mind on the left-hand side now I think
about the right-hand side what's going
to be different if you can see instead
of having - and into the negative case
I'm going to go y equals 2x plus one
minus the positive case and X plus one
is ready on that okay all right now just
that's all I need to graph this it so my
question so I make you this space so
negative one that's a point at which
things change so X plus one I already
know what that looks like right so I'm
just going to get mad that's y equals x
plus one so you've got that that
original yes Craig so downloaded maybe
like that without the other bracket is
not the question of graphically Arnold
yes the time the turn but I said look on
the right of negative warden that's what
it is a naturalistic Bluebird on the
Left of maybe one yeah
what is y equals 3x plus 3 look like
this people it's just steep up now if I
wrap the whole thing it would look
something like it's very if that's so it
is do you agree that has to be y equals
2x plus straight right there's the e 2
set free and so great of you write your
run is one your rise is three that's a
great free but cuz I actually want this
popular is complete why don't I want it
out slide that domain so I we want this
part down here so y equals 3x plus 3 I'm
done this is how you see better so
yeah sure how to go despite everyone or
do you have any other absolute value was
before I move on the crater bones so
that ye your son you know how you just
go the absolute absolute value graph
like you say a kid demands are for X is
less than minus 1 and X is greater than
1
yes so why do you just like why can't
you basis equip 2 of X plus 9
yes okay so the idea is see this thank
you this guy is always 2 times X plus 1
no matter what value X you put into it
it's always that it doesn't change then
I want to maybe supply you can say X is
less than negative 1 X is less than
negative 100 X is greater than 4 pi or
whatever this I don't care he'll always
be that if this guy that decides to be
this or that depending on what value of
x you supply ok if you supply a W that's
a net less than negative 1 it'll tell
you this if you supply value that's
greater than negative 1 it'll tell you
something else so this is the part of
the equation that changes this plant
does not change so that's why I ignore
that part when I'm in that domain this
is the impartial manner okay so for any
of the graphic that you just like so
it's like X minus 3 your domain would be
4 X is greater than Y so if you're
fishing with this you ask yourself where
does this be change when does it become
1 graph or another and the answer is
this guy changes at x equals 3 right at
x equals 3 it's exactly zero so that
means to the left of 3 negative this
changes to the right of 3 it's positive
so there is something else ok so you
just look carefully at whatever has two
values you've got you can have more than
one we've seen this before those high
questions they will look like this it's
just
both of those - those are some time
something like this right because it's
two nouns it now easy here it changes
from negative two and negative two but
it also changes for one and one on the
left of the right so that's why this
site has more cases it's more
complicated than this okay
so you look at every absolute value and
you say okay well it's going to change I
gotta find out the point that it changes
and in this case that's one it